[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it is seven o'clock this is sky news
tonight and breaking news in the last
hour plans to send first-year asylum
seekers to rwanda next week will go
ahead
the high court rules that the
government's new plan to tackle illegal
channel crossings can go ahead the home
secretary says that she will not be
deterred
well coming up i'm going to be joined by
a panel of experts to discuss the
controversial policy and this evening's
decision also tonight
rising fuel costs and pricier shopping
bills lead to three quarters of us
worrying about the cost of living on a
daily basis
we report from the cities on the front
line in ukraine as the final desperate
evacuations take place
despite all the chaos that we saw with
people attempting
to leave cities in the east at the
beginning of the war it's still going on
hundreds and hundreds are coming out
every single day
all right have you got any injuries
whereabouts have you been stabbed
no not me the neighbours the neighbors
been stabbed by whom
bye mate
the chilling recording of a former
soldier who killed his two neighbors is
played to the court in an ongoing murder
trial
plus covet cases rise in the uk for the
first time in two months but is it
anything to worry about
[Music]
hi there very good evening to you the
first flight due to deport asylum
seekers to rwanda is set to go ahead
next week the high court rejected a
legal challenge which hoped to stop
around 30 people being sent to east
africa after they illegally crossed the
channel well the new policy form parts
of the government's plan to tackle
illegal crossings and of course human
trafficking though it may not quite be
settled yet as human rights groups have
been granted the right to appeal in
three days time well coming up we'll be
speaking to a panel of experts about the
controversial policy and of course the
alternatives which could be out there
but first let's talk to our political
correspondent maria aurora she joins us
now live
amari the high court refusing to grant
an injunction just in the last half an
hour or so what does this mean then for
next week's flight
yes exactly so as far as it looks so far
it means that flight is going ahead
those kind of 30-yard
refugees potentially going to be sent to
rwanda uh next week obviously you can
never say never until uh that flight
does take off there's always a chance
perhaps uh those appeals uh on monday
might change things but for now it's
happening now this will be seen as a
kind of a big triumph for the government
and specifically for pretty patel uh
it's been a really long journey for them
it's been a very difficult policy for
them to get through a controversial
policy and one that was actually uh not
necessarily loved by many of their own
mps on the tory benches as well
so a bit of a triumph there but also
pretty patel she has actually reacted
with a statement about this court ruling
and she said i welcome the court's
decision in our favor and will now
continue to deliver on progressing our
world leading migration partnership
people will continue to try and prevent
their relocation through legal
challenges and last minute claims but we
will not be deterred in breaking the
deadly people smuggling trade and
ultimately saving lives now
that statement obviously very strong
there from pretty patel we can see she's
uh pleased about that court ruling now
it's important to remember this isn't a
court ruling on the policy it was a
court ruling on the application for an
injunction to stop that flight going
ahead so it doesn't mean that the policy
might potentially in the future be ruled
and lawful that hasn't actually happened
yet so it's important to remember that
that is still a possibility but i think
on the government badges benches tonight
there will be uh some definite uh
feeling of triumph there now it's also
important to remember that the
government is under huge pressure at the
moment to prove that they are kind of uh
making good on their promises on
especially kind of manifesto commitments
and promises that they've made over the
past couple of years
to the public they're very very worried
about the fact that we're kind of coming
into election season within the next
year or so and they need to be able to
say that they have actually uh executed
some of their policies that they said
they were going to do so pretty patel
under huge pressure there also a lot of
the tory mps especially tory mps and
specific seats
some in the red wall and elsewhere whose
constituents are constantly writing to
them under huge kind of pressure it was
one of one of the kind of top three
things that comes into a lot of these
mps inboxes that they're telling me is
these small boats crossing so they are
under huge pressure there and they will
be exerting that pressure on to pretty
patel and the rest of the government too
okay murray thank you very much
we can speak now to jacqueline mckenzie
jacqueline is an immigration lawyer who
was a member of the independent advisory
group that delivered the windrush
lessons learned review back in 2020 also
joined tonight by political commentator
sam ashworth hayes and joined by graham
mcgregor he is campaign's manager at
detention action uh to all of you thank
you very much for joining us uh tonight
particularly on it on a friday evening
jacqueline let's come to you first we're
waiting for hours for this ruling
actually i think it was meant to come at
lunch time are you surprised that the
judge has decided to not grant this
injunction i am surprised actually
because i think particularly with the
intervention of the unhcr who raised
some really really valid points about
you know the evidence that they gave to
the home office and how the home office
may have misrepresented that evidence
and given the extent of discourse there
is about how unsafe it is to move people
so the substantive issues that i know
aren't weren't dealt with today but i
thought a judge would have aired on the
side of caution because it is only about
interim relief
sam what do you think i mean i know that
you i wouldn't say you're necessarily
a cheerleader or a fan of this policy
but you certainly have been um
you know backing up pretty detail on
this haven't you i think it's quite a
sensible approach to take in dealing
with finding a way that is somewhat
humane for limiting the flow of the
small boats over the channel
because if you don't have effective
control of your boards if you don't have
an effective way of preventing these
flows it undermines support for the
legitimate
migration
and of course it encourages people to
take what is a very dangerous crossing
okay and graham let's bring you in as
well before we get to our viewers
questions i mean what does this mean
then for the flight next week do you do
you expect that it will take off on
tuesday
well i think that's you know that's
still yet to be seen we're obviously
disappointed by this initial decision
from the high court um we are see we
have been granted application to appeal
when that appeal will be going ahead on
monday so we'll see what the outcome of
that is and we continue to be very
concerned about the safety and the
welfare of those people who are still
that those 30 or so people now who are
still being threatened with being sent
to rwanda
thankfully as part of the hearing today
um four of the claimants uh in our
challenge in our in our appeal in our
request uh asylum seekers uh who are
claiming is part of our request we're
taking off that flight so that's that in
some ways we're very relieved to hear do
you think it'll go ahead do you think
jackie jacqueline will see that flight
taking off on tuesday because the judge
has left the door open for legal
intervention yes i think what the judge
wants us to hear well firstly it's that
there's an appeal on monday so we don't
know how that's going to go but so i
mean i think um the the information that
we've now got that four people were
successful in their applications is
really quite encouraging because i think
the judge wants to hear more about the
individual claims rather than general
policies and the other 30 though
well um
i i think really it now needs i mean i
think i've had some concern about the
way this whole thing's been handled and
the way some of the cases have been
fought and i think it is important to
look at individual cases and the
individual issues and bring those to
court and i think people have to work on
that over the weekend okay now it is an
emotive piece of policy isn't it i know
that you've all got very strong views on
it we've been asking our viewers to send
us their questions and then we've had
lots and lots of them so let's have a
look at a few of them now and i'd love
to get all of you involved in this um a
lot of people asking today um sam will
come to you first on this um
where are most of people seeking asylum
from is it clear is there a pattern
developing i mean would you know the
answer to that anyway i wouldn't know it
off the top of my head but you do have
sort of certain patterns in the the sort
of people who make these journeys and in
particular the sort of people who this
policy is directed at these are usually
single young men of sort of a quite a
young age who are it's viewed sort of
capable of making this journey to aranda
and doing so safely
um and they're also the sort of migrants
who when they arrive in communities are
perhaps
more apt to cause some degree of social
uh disruption
so it's quite a well targeted policy
from that point of view jacqueline what
does that mean social disruption i mean
what on earth are you talking about we
do know where most of these people have
come from because the home office told
us so afghanistan syria iraq sudan
countries like those countries that all
have major problems we also know the
vast majority of people who claim asylum
in this country succeed
so you know you've got the home office
saying these are genuine refugees and
you've also got courts saying that these
are genuine refugees so why on earth are
they not being allowed the privilege or
the right to claim asylum in this
country
which international uh convention allows
for sam if i just might briefly come
back on that um we know where they've
been most recently which is france now
to my point of view and perhaps to the
audience as well france is quite a safe
and prosperous country and
three times as many people seeking
asylum do so in france and france
actually pays 20 euros a week more in
benefit so the idea that people are
coming here for our benefits or that
they're coming here in droves isn't true
and in fact we have about 30 000 people
crossing the channel there are over 100
million people displaced across the
globe there are 26 million refugees
across the globe there are 5 million
people seeking asylum right now we do
not have a crisis in this country
okay graeme let's bring you in now let's
talk about the legal processes we
understand this is the beginning of what
could be a protracted um legal process
um is this is a chance for lawyers to be
making money what do you make of the
legal process ahead of us
um well i mean i can only speak to our
legal challenge and our lawyers uh who
are acting pro bono in this case um our
legal challenge is being funded by
individual donations from the many many
members of the public of the british
public who support
what we're trying to do here which
essentially at the end of the day is to
test the legality of a very new and very
controversial government policy for
which there is a lot of evidence that
the home office and the home secretary
have not really properly thought this
through they have not uh you know taken
their time to make sure that it is safe
and that it is lawful so um no there is
not a lot of money to be made um
and
you know we will be pursuing our legal
case through to the end we expect it to
take about six to eight weeks
today's hearing um
we understand uh we're still looking at
the the judge's decision but we
understand that
part of the reason for the injunction
not being granted was that the the judge
in in the case um
felt that or believed that the people
being sent to rwanda next week wouldn't
be at risk of persecution uh or in any
risk of danger um in the six to eight
weeks it would take to decide the more
substantial case now we disagree with
that um but that certainly means that
the judge himself is not ruling out the
unlawfulness of this policy and he's not
ruling out the the riskiness of this
policy the danger that it may be putting
people in he's just saying it's not
going to happen in the time that it
takes to hear the full challenge
sam i know you've written extensively
about the role of lawyers and all of
this what would you like to say about
that i think it's just a really
interesting example of the way that the
the sort of
social and legal spheres in this country
are working almost in unison to obstruct
the government in its attempts to make
policy um and obviously what's wrong
with that
it's obviously legitimate for people to
take a view but at a certain point it
becomes about those who have the access
to lawyers who raise the funds to pay
for them and it sort of you can almost
set a veto on policy by sort of holding
up indefinitely through repetitive legal
challenges
um jackie let's bring you in now because
again we we get the impression certainly
from a lot of our viewers how um people
may be asking how a law and policy that
is created by government we know that
it's very pretty patel's backing it we
know that they believe it is legal that
boris johnson remains confident that the
policy is legal
whether how it's allowed to be
challenged by the high courts and
effectively not on this case but maybe
in the days and weeks to come a high
court judge can put a stop to it from
time immemorial people challenge
decisions of governments and policy of
governments and laws um you know that's
how it works that's how we get new law
and new policy and that's what's
happening here and whether you look at
things whether it's stop and search or
problems in schools or so forth you know
things get changed and some people are
saying and quite credible people experts
lawyers unhcr all those ngos like
detention action care for calais freedom
for torture etc are saying this is wrong
it's unlawful and so it has to be
challenged do you understand how voters
can be a bit frustrated by this i do
understand how voters can be a bit
frustrated by this because
it's basically it is one of the top
things within their email inbox yes but
it's no longer in the top 10 of issues
that voters are concerned with we we
have that evidence um i can understand
why voters are concerned because they
haven't been given the information and
those that data that i don't want to
keep rounding off those large numbers
but people really do believe that there
is a crisis in this country with people
seeking asylum and there isn't one and
there's lots of things that can be done
so for instance yeah what is wrong with
you i mean that would be great to hear
from you so we get very small numbers to
start with all right um
this summer well yes i mean you know we
we had about 28 000 last year in the
scheme of 100 million people displaced
in the world we are one of the richest
countries depending on which measurement
you use we're either the third or the
fourth richest country in the world
we should be doing our bit now people
talk about i mean you know well you know
it's costing us so much well why don't
we let asylum seekers work we've got
huge shortages in this country um you
know we had to bring in people because
as a result of brexit we had to bring in
people to work in in you know in farm on
farms pick strawberries you know
we needed butchers amongst all the
people i've ever worked with who have
sought asylum and nearly every single
one of them has got it so have proved
that they're a genuine refugee and i've
been at this for a very very long time
you have people with
incredible skills you know skilled
doctors and and so forth and you have
people with low level skills the country
needs these sorts of people sam it's a
very valid point isn't it again an
article that i that i read that you
wrote not that long ago you were talking
about the uk being attracted because
it's got such a strong workforce or you
know jobs jobs are plenty and we know
there's a need for jobs so as jacqueline
says
wouldn't these wouldn't these so-called
asylum seekers be fantastic in those
roles i think that's exactly the
opposite of what you want to do um if
you give people the right to work and to
earn income it becomes a tough sort of
sort of back door for economic migration
even more is at present you provide a
massive pull factor for people to come
from around the world as jaclyn says
there's a lot of people some currently
displaced so i'm not currently displaced
who'd want to make use of that
opportunity
you know we may not have numbers which
are a crisis right now we can disagree
on that but it's certainly the case that
this is a phenomenon which is growing
and it's something we'd like to take
control of so that we actually have a
stable and secure border policy
if you give people more incentives to
move to britain through this route then
more people will come and that's exactly
the opposite of what we want but there's
no evidence that this is growing in fact
the numbers are down and i know kovid
has had some impact on that but we've
got to look at the data
there's a lot of um i don't know um you
know
suggestions and and all and and and
people just making things up we've got
to really study the data here and if we
start to do that we'll realize the
problem isn't as bad as we think it is
okay for graham you've been waiting
patiently so let's bring you in with
another with another opinion and this
being you know if if asylum seekers make
a journey through seven or eight
different countries in order to get to
the uk i mean what what is it about the
uk and and if they're able to find
safety in the likes of france why don't
they stay there
so i think first and foremost to just to
repeat what jacqueline already said is
that the uk you know proportionately
even within europe we rank 14th in terms
of asylum applications per head of
population so even taking account of the
larger populations of other countries in
europe we're still in the 14s this idea
that you know we're somehow taking
droves and droves of people is simply
not true um
i would say that you know we know we
work with uh many asylum seekers who are
held in immigration detention and in the
preparation for this case we've spoken
to many of those who are being who are
facing being sent uh you know by force
to rwanda
many of them
have existing connections to the uk uh
cultural connections they may have i
mean there are afghans who are supposed
to be on next week's flight uh who may
have served as interpreters or worked
with you know british armed forces in
afghanistan we know for example that
there are um people who are on next
week's flight who have family members in
the uk who've made a long journey a very
dangerous journey we would absolutely
agree that it's dangerous they made that
long dangerous journey to get here only
to be
you know locked up in a detention center
put in shackles forced onto a plane to
rwanda and sent 4000 miles in the
opposite direction and we think that's
just unacceptable and unnecessary the
reality is that
and coming back to what jacqueline was
saying about you know the data and the
numbers let's you know be specific
there are no for for the vast majority
of these uh these people seeking asylum
and the nationalities that they are
there are no safe routes to reach the uk
to seek asylum in the uk there is no way
to apply for asylum from another country
outside the uk
and this government over the last
several years has progressively shut
down or closed off or limited more and
more of those safe routes that you know
myself and many of my
many other people are calling for all
the time um we had 5000 syrians a year
coming through safe routes that was shut
down in early 2021 we've had none since
then there's no other way for syria to
get here
afghans
after that initial evacuation
recently
the government committed to opening up
more safe routes for afghans none of
those have been opened nothing has
materialized okay great so afghanistan
let me bring sam back in because you are
looking perplexed
so i think it's uh these are almost
distinct points the availability of safe
routes is fantastic that's you know i
think everyone would agree that's
preferable to people crossing the
channel
um this is about discouraging unsafe
routes so you can have distinct as
distinct policies making available safe
groups for people to come here and
trying to close off the routes which we
really want to discourage so i think
they're you know to to apply the two
government is only doing one of those
the government is only
introducing a deterrent and trying to
punish those people who are left with no
choice but to come by dangerous route
they're not introducing safe routes and
truly i think we could all agree that if
you know you have to do both at the same
time or else you just end up putting
people in an impossible position where
they have no choice but to take it to
finish them yeah
but if you do in fact think they should
be doing both at the same time then
wouldn't it be more productive to push
your efforts towards providing those
safe routes rather than shutting off the
uh deterrent for the dangers we've been
holding
repeatedly for months throughout the
passage of the nationality and borders
bill we put forward amendments to that
bill with support from mps in the house
uh calling for the introduction of a
humanitarian visa program that would
allow people to apply for safe passage
from elsewhere in the world and the
government refused it repeatedly without
explaining why
um and then i'll come to you
but you do in principle think that this
channel crossing route should be
deterred
we think that the way to to uh
persuade people not to take that route
or not even persuade them because in
many cases they have no choice if they
want to reach the uk and have good
reason to do so we think that you offer
them safe alternatives that's the way to
undermine the people smuggling model is
to provide people with what they test
what they clearly desperately need as
jacqueline pointed out in relative terms
uh even for a country the size of the uk
with the population we have it's not a
large number of people it's a tiny
proportion of our annual uh migration
immigration
um you provide them with what they need
which is a safe way to get here and seek
asylum i'm keen to bring jacqueline back
in graham thank you i'm keen to give me
will it provide a deterrent i mean
because pushy patel boris johnson said
that they're targeting the the criminal
people smugglers here and this will be a
deterrent it won't be a deterrent
because if people are genuinely fleeing
persecution which most of them go on to
prove
then they're going to flee and they're
going to find whatever way they can and
there's nothing in international
conventions or international law that
prevents people from doing that even
crossing the channel
we've seen an attempt at safe routes
with ukraine it hasn't worked so what we
want are various systems we want to be
able to facilitate people who decide to
take the risk in order to protect
themselves but we also do need
some measures that help people uh
come across in what we call safe routes
but you know you can sort of imagine a
woman in in in kabul trying to find a
safe route to get out of there
of course it's going to be impossible so
people need to flee in whatever way they
can and when they get here we need to
facilitate that and accommodate them and
treat them humanely and act within
international conventions very briefly
sam before i move to the next question
but again we're sort of um missing a
sort of point here which is that they
have already made it to europe they're
not they're no longer fleeing couple
they're now leaving front they're
entitled to move on you see
international law allows that they are
entitled to move on we know there are
all sorts of reasons historic reasons
empire colonialism family connections
cultural ties why people choose this
country but we've already heard that
we're way down the list in european
countries that take asylum seekers and
most people don't try to come to the uk
let's move on lots of thoughts
surrounding how other countries have
done it particularly the issue of
australia we know that australia is very
tough when it comes to immigration
policies has a similar policy worked in
australia
it certainly worked to um deter sort of
what they call the boat crossings over
there although they also have quite an
aggressive turnback policy which
obviously we haven't implemented in the
uk
and yeah they have quite a strict
immigration system i went through it
when i lived out there
okay right okay graham what would you
think what would you add to that
so i i worked um
as refugee campaign of ramsey
international australia for four years i
went to australia's offshore detention
center on manus island and
conducted research there about the
conditions and the abuses carried out
against the innocent people most of whom
were refugees who were being detained
there against their will for
ultimately about seven eight years um
with no prospect of release we do not
want to go down that route and that's
part of the reason that we are so
opposed to this rwanda policy is because
we know where it can potentially lead
you know numerous deaths unavoidable
deaths in offshore detention centers
operated by the australian authorities
really you know extensive child abuse
that just went unchecked and unobserved
it really was a very grim situation and
the reality is if you look at the
statistics from australia
sam's not entirely wrong about those
statistics that offshore detention
itself was not a deterrent the deterrent
policy itself was ineffective
in the 12 months
after offshore detention was
reintroduced before the australian
government began pushing boats back
numbers of people arriving by boat
continued to be about the same
it was only when the australian
government started to push back boats
back to indonesia
that the numbers dropped because of
course they did because they were
pushing votes back but of course the
reality there is that when those people
are pushed back they don't disappear
they don't you know vanish into a puff
of smoke as i think you know sometimes
people would like to think they do they
simply re-enter that global migration
that global movement of people they're
re-exposed to incredible dangers um
again at the hands of traffickers
ironically um and they're left with no
alternative but to take dangerous routes
once again and many those people that
australia expelled will have tried to
make the journey to europe and may have
even you know attempted to reach the uk
okay graeme thank you very much i want
to give the last word to jacqueline if
you don't mind i mean i'm sure you've
got a comment on on australia and also
how's this going to pan out i mean are
we going to see
say asylum seekers on flights to rwanda
do you think next week and for the rest
of the summer i think i echo everything
graham said on australia i mean
everybody who's researched it have come
up with the absolute horror stories and
for a country that's built on migration
i think it's really quite shocking um
that we're trying to emulate what they
were doing um breaching human rights in
every possible way um
i think the government is determined to
do it because it thinks it's something
that its base wants to happen i think
that's why they're doing it i don't
think that
in their hearts they really believe that
this is a good thing to do nobody could
possibly believe this is a good thing to
do
but i think they believe it plays out to
the electorate a certain section of the
electorate
um and and so every effort will be made
but every effort will be made by these
wonderful ngos and all lawyers do is
what they're trained to do which is to
fight uh cases that we think well if
you're a human rights lawyer which we
think breach human rights is the courts
that make the decisions but you know i
think those ngos are out there
working to protect and guarantee human
rights and i think that's going to
continue so i think it's going to be a
very battle a big battle and even if
this flight leaves on tuesday that's not
the end of it this is a long-term policy
this isn't just the home secretary
wanting the symbolism of one plane
leaving it's a long-term policy we
understand they've been talking to
zambia and
ghana to to to do more of this to have
more of these deals and which we call
human trafficking so it's gonna be it's
gonna be our strategy from now on and
people are going to fight it and at some
point there will be wins okay 10 seconds
to come back sam i just think it's a
very effective policy for deterring um
extremely dangerous channel crossings i
think it's a strong deterrent for people
who are
you know choosing their country from
amongst safe havens and i think numbers
have gone up in the last few weeks it's
not implemented yet well no but it's
it's out there and you know people know
about it so in fact that's the deterrent
the deterrent is that you're saying this
is what we're going to do there's a
flight book but i mean do you think
people are still coming but you've just
told me we're going to have all these
legal challenges and the policy may not
actually happen yes but no but people
out there or the people seeking asylum
have heard that we're going to send them
to rwanda but they're still coming do
they believe that they don't know
anything about what's going to happen in
the courts people are fleeing personally
do you not believe that people let them
come back
i'm sure they're thinking persecution
but i think once you're making the
choice between living in italy
switzerland france or britain then that
stage of the journey has passed doing
that and i'm glad you said you do
believe they're fleeing persecution i
think that's the end of the story if
people are doing that we should treat
them humanely
we'll leave it there thank you very much
for joining us a really enlightening uh
conversation i know that this is a story
that we shall come back and talk to you
about again jacqueline mckenzie sam
ashworth hayes and graham mcgregor thank
you very much for your thoughts this
evening and of course that decision
graham thank you very much that decision
is sure to feature in tomorrow's
newspapers we're going to have our
extended press preview and news review
from 10 30 this evening with tonight's
news and tomorrow's headlines joining us
will be the fleet street fox and daily
mirror columnist susie bonifas and also
freddie gray deputy editor of the
spectator make sure you tune in for that
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up after this short break the neighborly
dispute that ended in two deaths a court
hears chilling evidence of how an
ex-commando stabbed a couple as their
children slept upstairs
[Music]
[Music]
you